well we hate to report this but so far
12 clark county school district students
have taken their lives
this school year as kristin drummond
reports this is a serious concern that
the district is looking to address with
a new platform
to monitor the well-being of students
and staff
the pandemic this year put a spotlight
on mental health to address it the board
of trustees unanimously approved
thursday to make a significant
investment
we have a lot of kids out there right
now with a lot of very severe needs
addressing social and emotional learning
i want to recognize the fact that this
is something that's been
voiced by the trustees for a long time
board members authorized spending 761
thousand dollars to purchase panorama
education's data platform survey
an investment made with federal cares
dollars so if we wanted to continue to
use this platform
a year from now we're going to have to
come up with that
amount when you're losing kids and kids
and staff
that are suffering uh with what we're
what we're facing we just have to
prioritize this
within our budget superintendent dr
jesus jaw says
the district already piloted the
platform in 12 schools
he anticipates an additional 50
participating next month
before we roll it out to all 360 schools
we have to have a strategic approach to
make sure that we can staff it
here we can see a summary of the
students sel results
the platform provides another resource
for schools to monitor the well-being of
students
and staff with an assessment the results
identify a person's mental health with a
red
yellow or green color obviously the red
is where we need to
identify and provide some assistance a
multi multi-disciplinary leadership team
that will meet with the kids face to
face
to provide the support addressing
concerns to try and avoid another
student
dying by suicide kristin drummond 8 news
now
we did ask the district for a copy of
the survey to get a look at the
questions ourselves dr jarrah says
principals are choosing at this moment
to participate in the rollout
the well-being screener is for students
in grades 3
through 12.